so I'm looking at some of the stuff that  musk likes and I'm getting a bit more  optimistic  and then you know when he said um  she was in per she wasn't uh she was  impersonated for she was banned from  personally comedian that's funnier than  anything that Kathy Griffin has ever  said that's true that's funnier than her  career and this tells me that he takes  great personal satisfaction in seeing  Justice served to those who have been  living high on the hog for far too long  abusing and  um uh insulting uh  the rest of us while not allowing us to  respond in kind and that tells me that  he is  powerfully motivated to see Justice Done  publicly  so do you think the Kathy Griffin was a  good move or a bad move it's phenomenal